Speaker 1: Yesterday, I came to you with the
news that Alex Jones Infowars website has
filed for Chapter 11 bankruptcy protection,
and I said, Hey, listen, we've got to be careful
with this because it seems that it is obviously
a way to keep and hide money from being subject
to settlements because the guy is being sued
to high heaven and it's not going well.
But it's still interesting.
He, immediately after the bankruptcy went
public, announced an emergency blowout, and
I'm not talking about a diaper blowout caused
by all those weird supplements that he takes.
I I'm talking about an emergency blowout sale
of these kooky products that he has on his
website, so wasting absolutely no time whatsoever.
Here is Alex Jones big announcement.
Listen, if you've not gotten drinkable silver,
this would be a great opportunity to do it.
Speaker 3: You want us to be able to stay
on air and be able to move forward in the
future.
I need you
Speaker 1: don't really want that.
That's the thing
Speaker 3: now to not wait and to go to Infowars
store dot com.
Especially those of you that I never bought
a book about a film about a T-shirt.
Ever got a shop?
Speaker 1: Imagine buying a film from Alex
Jones.
That is something, huh?
Speaker 3: I never got an air filtration.
Water filtration.
Shortwave radio, thousands of great items,
books, you name it, at Infowars store, dot
com, get your living defense, get your knock
out.
It's back in stock body's ultimate turmeric
formula.
Speaker 1: Long cleanse the lung, cleanse
there isn't.
There's a product I would buy.
I actually was thinking to myself what could
possibly be going on in someone's life where
you go to Alex Jones store to get a lung cleanser?
I mean, what?
If you fall for that, you could fall for anything.
Speaker 3: They're all there and Infowars
store icon.
And it's just that simple, there's also a
button up on the top of the shopping cart
that says support.
And it has become a sponsor and you just click
there and you can give a monthly donation
or just a one time donation.
And then we actually get 95 percent of that
money instead of just, you know, 30 or 40
percent, 50 percent with the sale of the products
show.
This is do or die time if you want to keep
a show on air.
These attacks on the system and the system
pulling out all the stops
Speaker 1: to, you know, the crazy thing is
like, I've never met a genuine fan of Alex
Jones.
I've met people who watch his content because
it's so crazy and they're like, We do, right?
I mean, we kind of keep an eye on what all
of these extremists do.
I have never met someone who seriously watches
Alex Jones
Speaker 3: at a silence.
Since then, this is the time they are trying
to silence you.
They're trying to take down the leading voice
of resistance.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
If Alex Jones is the leading voice of resistance,
we're really in trouble.
Our good friend, Farron Cousins, had a good
tweet with similar thoughts to mine from yesterday
about the entire bankruptcy thing.
Farron tweeted, Quote a lot of people celebrating
Alex Jones filing for bankruptcy, but that
move just screws over the victims and allows
him to shield money from them that they would
otherwise be able to go after.
This move protects him and his money and is
not a good thing.
Farran going on to say the filing also lets
him restructure his business holdings in order
to keep operating.
So the hatred and conspiracies aren't going
away, so I don't trust the entire bankruptcy
thing any further than I'd be able to throw
Alex Jones.
I don't.
It just it stinks to high heaven, like I said
yesterday, and there are lots of people celebrating
it.
And I mean, listen, you can be for speech,
but for the failure of certain types of speech,
right?
I mean, this and this is this is like an age
old battle and debate.
For example, I used to interview these people
from the Westboro Baptist Church, and they
were the ones who would show up at soldiers
funerals with signs that would say, You know,
God hates these people and those people at,
you know, the people.
I could recognize that they have a right to
speak now.
You know, there are different laws around
protesting at funerals and things like that.
But let's generally just say I recognize that
people have a right to express their opinion.
But at the same time, I can be thrilled if
their opinion is so unsavory that they sort
of like, go out of business.
And that's kind of what's happened with the
Westboro Baptist Church.
I'm not saying that they're bankrupt, but
they have become so out of favor where even
the small amount of interest that there was
in their message has evaporated and they're
nowhere now.
I think that that's fantastic.
I'm not against free speech because they're
free.
Their speech is unpopular.
And similarly, there is absolutely no question
whatsoever that Alex Jones is allowed to have
a show the government shouldn't can't legally.
I mean, they shouldn't be censoring him.
Platforms can decide based on their terms
of service whether what Alex Jones does, is
or isn't allowed.
But it's OK to be happy if Alex Jones particular
speech is so distasteful that it becomes financially
unviable.
Not viable.
That's a great thing.
I'm happy about that.
And it's not about, Oh David, do you?
Do you wish that?
Yeah, my Alex Jones impression, right?
Globalist, internationalist, Trotskyites socialist
run like Obama, Trudeau, Macron and the rest
of the 0B.
Yeah, it's it's OK.
I think it's a great thing if his speech is
considered so disgusting that he can't make
money off of it.
Call me crazy.
I think that that's a good thing